yet again emmanuel macron and marine le
pen will fight for the top job in france
the first round of the vote finished
with no clear winner it's a tight race
in the second round so can the far right
win
and what would that mean for france this
is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
nick clark president macron is in the
north of france already campaigning for
a runoff election on april the 24th he's
on top after the first round of voting
took place on sunday and he wants to
become the first french president to be
re-elected in the last 20 years but his
contender marine le pen is not far
behind determined to start her own
presidency by winning the runoff polling
suggests a much tighter race this time
than when the two last faced each other
back in 2017
then more than 26 percent of the
population abstain from casting a ballot
on the first round photosmith filed this
report now from paris
emanuel macron only did one campaign
rally but the man who brands himself a
centrist did enough to have a chance of
being the first incumbent french
president in 20 years to win a second
term
again though he'll have to beat the far
right
to all the french who chose to abstain
or the vote on the extreme either
because they're angry faced with
persistent inequality a damaged planet
everyday insecurity the difficulty to
make a decent living despite working
hard
i want to convince them in the coming
days
his opponent in the second round of
voting will again be marine le pen
leader of the national rally its
manifesto includes a promise to make it
illegal for muslim women to wear
headscarves in public places
your vote depends all over the french
territory on the legitimate
preponderance of the french culture and
language the customs of our regions and
the french way of life on republican
laws and values
le pen might pick up votes from
supporters of eric zemor another extreme
right candidate the former tv pundit has
asked his supporters to back her in the
second round
the far left jean-luc melenchon had
hoped that this time he might make it to
the runoff but again he didn't quite get
enough votes
france's traditional right and left-wing
parties continue to hemorrhage support
the conservative the republicans party
and the valerie peckress saw their share
of the vote collapsed to single digits
the socialists under ann hidalgo have
been all but wiped out their share of
the vote barely registered
the beneficiary of those former
conservative and socialist votes seems
again to be macron
we actually ask the french voters to
support actually a strong european
france for the next turn of the
elections in two weeks
i believe we have a good record and we
have a worked out plan with a vision for
the future for the young our country and
for the workers
to the left macron has promised higher
pensions and more staff in health care
for the right thousands more police
officers and judges and a rise in the
retirement age from 62 to 65.
so now there'll be two weeks of intense
campaigning for emmanuel macron and
marine le pen most of the losing
candidates have urged their supporters
not to let the pen win so macron could
benefit from their votes but the far
right won a combined 33 share of the
vote in the first round so an upset
cannot be ruled out
bernard smith inside story paris
well the merging of the right wing into
the far right is one of the biggest
developments of this election uh marine
le pen and eric zamor's combined poll
ratings amount to an unprecedented 30
plus for the far right in front whose
parties are more united than those on
the left the far right agree on what
they say is the necessity for france to
re-establish its fuel its full
sovereignty from the european union they
also want to limit or end immigration
and some of the right-wing go as far as
saying islam is incompatible with the
french republic
over the past two years they have spread
from a fringe movement to a mainstream
political force in france and that's
been fueled by economic grievances and
security fears after isil attacks on
french soil
all right let's bring in our guests from
paris we have jacques relonde who is the
senior research fellow at the global
policy institute from newcastle in
england on skype ariane bogaine who's a
senior lecturer in french and politics
at northumbria university and and
elizabeth mutate joins us she's a
paris-based columnist for the telegraph
and unheard online magazine a warm
welcome to you all everybody will look
at the results first and then we'll
project on to what might happen in the
second round and the crucial
parliamentary elections in that upcoming
tv debate but first the first round
results and elizabeth
you have written how
le pen was almost a write-off three
months ago
what happened
well i also wrote last week that she had
made an extraordinary comeback actually
almost a resurrection
um it's very interesting because it's a
combination of what she's been trying to
do for the past at least four or five
years and
a situation in which she
mechanically looked more quote unquote
moderate because of the advent of eric
zimmer a new player who's a former
columnist for luffy yahoo and who looked
and sounded more hardline than she she
did
so suddenly the entire effort that she's
put into rebranding her party changing
the name from national front to national
rally which is more consensual turning
down her platform and we can talk about
this further uh and uh even sort of uh
giving off
personal vibes of her personality as
being somebody who was milder
who was less abrasive somebody who
gave smaller rallies on her competitors
and didn't shy from admitting to
mistakes from saying that things were
sometimes things went wrong all of this
built up a kind of constituency that
related to her and um um you everybody
has sort of been counting the zamor vote
into the marine le pen vote in two weeks
time uh she is actually she's got a core
constituency that were people that voted
communist 25 years ago and she at least
one third of jean-luc minajo the hard
leftist voters may actually vote for her
uh in two weeks time because she speaks
for the working class and she has a very
left-wing social program in terms of
benefit and changes except that she
wants it only for the french
ariana bogaine do you agree with that
what's your overview of how this panned
out
yeah i agree with with what's uh being
said i think a strategy paid off she
decided very early on that she would
focus on cost of living and it has been
rising in france as the you know as has
just been said she was made even more
moderate by uh by zimur
and i think as well uh you know macron
for me had a a really bad campaign in in
in the first round you know he started
very late uh he refused to do any any
debate and his messaging was terrible
because the main
takeaway that voters ordinary voters who
don't have time or inclination to read
through the program line by line the
only thing that they remembered was
you'll have to work longer so it's a
it's you know a strategy paid off and
there was also some tactical voting uh
from uh simul voter and from uh the
republican rights voters uh to ensure
that that she is in the second round so
i agree with what's been said but i
think we shouldn't underestimate uh also
that macro had a bad campaign in my in
my opinion all right macro had a bad
campaign the jack jack red line do you
do you think uh the first round ended up
being tighter than emmanuel macron
thought it would
yes i'm sure yes i agree with both uh
both speakers that the
le pen made a good campaign macron made
a terrible campaign and i think he
suffered a bit from hubris like here now
especially the reform uh of the pension
age that he wants to rise to 65 you
announced it in his first big address to
the french people at a time where he was
riding at 32
in the opinion pose
but it's a measure which has actually
displeased many people in france
working in 65 it was
and also linking some supplementary
benefits to extra work or training on
the part of workers that has upset a lot
of people on the left and that's where
he has to gain some support and that's
why many people on the left especially
on the far left are very opposed to
macron there's a sense of hatred even
towards him
and
now
he i think he's realized his mistake and
that
he at the time he thought that he needed
to take votes away from valerie peckress
but as we see valerie pecas is 45 so
there not many votes to be gained there
if he wants to gain votes in the second
round it they have to come from the left
so the nature of this campaign will have
to change he will have to campaign much
more announce some more measure
and uh
there will be a big debate and he has to
show to the french people that his
program is not a very liberal right-wing
program but there's it's a balanced
program with measures to help
the working classes and the poor and the
weak
which is which he started today by going
campaigning on the hunting round of the
the far left or the round of marine le
pen in the north of france in a town
where the majority of people voted for
marine le pen and he has to convince
them that his uh policies will be more
beneficial to them than those of le pen
and i don't think it would be that
difficult because le pen's economic
program le pen has made loads of
promises to all people the speech she
made last night there was money for
everyone she was going to do a week the
podium
etc it was a list it was a catch-all
kind of uh okay
all right jack okay
let me let me move back to elizabeth so
so jack says jacqueline says elizabeth
that uh macron has realized his mistake
will it be enough uh he himself admits
that it's certainly not over yet and
poll predictions for the second round
are well within the margin of error as
our reporter bernie smith says it's not
out of this world to imagine that le pen
could win this
i think yes it's very interesting
because the cross voting and the people
who sort of voted on one side are going
to vote for somebody whom you wouldn't
think at firsthand is
i mean major just i've just mentioned
the minority voters voting for
marine le pen uh but on the other side
you've got you've got i know zimwi
voters who will vote for emmanuel macron
because they felt rightly or wrongly
that their candidate was still
forward-looking and modern and wanted to
create a sort of large right-wing party
that would have been something like uh i
don't know if you in british terms the
tory party with adam knight or ferrara
for instance whereas uh they can't they
find that marine le pen is much more
rigid and and backwards looking uh and
that constituency does exist um it's i
mean it's a complicated it's very
complicated to calculate the uh
uh the votes on either side i think
emmanuel macron probably should win it
uh but the entire campaign has been
painted in the first and second round
that's the first round is very new as a
kind of what again the british would
call project fear the other one is evil
so uh on on the on the hard right you
people say uh look emmanuel macron is
the man who's bringing in foreigners
he's the man who's uh abandoning
sovereignty of france to europe all
sorts of things and on the other side
you've got essentially the great line of
you know let's find let's have a new uh
french fascism which was a great
movement to gain fascism in the 1930s in
france and it's not going to be a very
grown-up campaign and where marine le
pen is shrewd that is that she always
brings back uh the situation with the
hardships that people are experiencing
especially now that inflation is going
up macro now suffers from something from
last time last time he was new
many people voted for him because he was
the new guy he was younger he annoyed
all the others and therefore he was a
safe populist vote you know somebody who
still had
the competencies within the french
techno structure and somebody who
annoyed the other candidates the
incumbents rested left and right this
time he's been in power for five years
in his big rally at lady falls west
paris he talked about uh um a cab uh
homes personal he talked about doctors
he talked about all sorts of people who
were suffering and the immediate
reaction of so many people is well you
know who was president at that time you
were uh so it's it's going to be tight
it's difficult to predict uh i still
think like the bookmakers that uh macron
will squeeze through but it's going to
be it's going to be difficult there is
this long-lasting discontent isn't there
ever over his person over macros
personalities deemed arrogant by many
and maybe that was that arrogance was on
display and the fact that he didn't take
part in much of the electoral campaign
ariane bogano how do you see it panning
out this this second round
yeah again i agree um it's going to be
much tighter in 17 and you know in 17 it
was the new kid on the block and a lot
of people gave him the benefit of the
doubt now is the incumbent he you know
he has a whole presidency under his belt
and people know what he did and he
generated a lot of anger a lot of hatred
in some quarters a lot of discontentment
so it's much easier for marino ben to
point at this is what he did do you want
the song for five years whereas in 17 it
was uh i i possesses of what or what he
might do um i think it will really come
down to abstention rate uh on the left
and to how many voters uh sorry how many
middle shore voters will switch to le
pen there was a study this morning i
believe that suggested thirty percent
will abstain so of militia voters thirty
percent will vote for le pen
this is going to be the crucial point
how high is the abstention going to be
on the left and how many voters from
elongation will switch i think he might
squeeze through but it's not going to be
you know
66 34 like it was last time right jack
that's that's very interesting isn't it
it will be key the number of abstentions
won't it because
i mean you know isn't abstaining
effectively a vote for le pen
yes i mean the far left uh jean-luc
bernard schwarzkopf
slogan i mean appeal was to say to the
people do not vote for marie le pen but
he did not say vote for macron right
obviously but that's been
that's been the case for
most of the leaders except except eric
zemu and eric ciot
on the
as a republican uh petra's backer
so there's a few people have called for
a vote to well to le pen but quite a lot
have said
even on the left the ecologist in adidas
have clearly said even valerie pecres
has clearly said that she would she
would vote for macron as far as they
moved i agree with
elizabeth some some of them will not
want to vote for le pen because the
african economic program is incoherent
and that's
we can see in this divide in france that
macron appeals to the
the france the french were doing well
and marine le pen appeals to those who
are
who find it hard to make ends meet but
in the debate that's why i think the key
point would be for macron to show in
this next two weeks that his program
is the one who is best suited to uh the
interest of the working-class people
being voted out of anger towards le pen
and
that's in that sense he's got something
to back it up because his record is very
good especially on employment during his
mandate more than 1.2 million jobs were
created and french employment rate is at
its lowest that it's been for a long
time it was not even an issue the issue
was the cost of living and even there
macron will be able to prove
if there is a debate and the debate on
television will be crucial
whether marine le pen has improved her
competence in the field of economics
right exactly because because she really
struggled back in 2017 didn't she ariana
yes that as jacques says
that tv debate i think it's on the 20th
is going to be you know a real pivot
point
yes definitely i mean last time around
it was it was a car crash and it really
cost her
you know dearly i mean she appeared
totally incompetent in 2017. so uh you
know
you would you would think that she would
have learned from it and that she would
be a bit better this time round but yeah
it is going to be crucial and uh you
know macron will have to you know to
push her on all our economic promises
because if you look at the program it's
you know there's something for everybody
great but how do you finance it so he
will ask all all those questions and
marilyn open will have to hope that she
does much better than in 17 because
otherwise it would be very easy for
macron to to highlight that she that
she's incompetent that she doesn't have
the competence that she doesn't know how
to you know to deal with crisis the way
he had to do during uh during his
present presidency so the debate is key
as well as ascension in my view okay i'd
like to continue that side of the
conversation but we've got to move it on
i want to talk about the the french
traditional parties and elizabeth we've
only got six or seven minutes left
what does this mean what's happening
here for french politics
is that it for the traditional parties
for the conservative right and the
socialist left
i think it's uh i i think it's actually
rather bad because what we end up having
is um
one candidate of the great and the good
who is emmanuel macron and two are
essentially bogey men or women bogey
persons and and that's not good for
democracy uh you you no longer have in a
position you know who you disagree with
but uh they are honorable people and
that's a real problem and that is
entirely the doing of emmanuel macron he
came five years ago seemingly out of
nowhere he'd been in the cabinet for 18
months uh with josue alonso socialist he
was not a member of the socialist party
himself when he came in he said i'm
going to do things on them at the same
time left and right uh you don't have to
choose between left and right and he
started shaving off personalities from
uh
the the right and the left and he always
picked sort of compatible docile
personalities and he gave them jobs and
forbade them to have political ideas of
their own and then he people the
national assembly with essentially
clothes of himself in many ways and the
result was a sort of anemic um national
sort of politics life which reduced the
the
the extent of the debate that i think is
bad for democracy i think he because he
at the end of the day
his nature is that he's a civil servant
he's a top mandarin he was at the
minister of finance he graduated top of
his class almost top of his class at
another french government school he is
used to people obeying him and not
people talking back to him okay and
that's really why he decided that he
would make a new system at his image
which i think is really wrong for
democracy jacques do you think in a
sense macron
you know by you know emasculating the
traditional parties he's
he's actually empowered his own
opposition
what is very interesting is yes macron
destroyed the socialist party in 2017
and now he has destroyed
the
the right the republican party the two
parties which have dominated french
political life for the last 50 years are
now in tatters so what's going to happen
after macron has a casual vote all in
the middle and what you're going to see
on the right is a recomposition i
uh the hard right
uh le pen the people in the republican
party who back to the pen like suited uh
the right wing
of the republican who were split like
the socialists were split in 2017
between governments and more radical
plus the same of voters all of that
would add up to a very outright party on
the uh on the right which could gather
about 30 35 of the of the of the voters
and have policies a bit similar to the
british tory party very nationalist a
very protectionist and
at the same time a very hostile to
foreigners so that's
that's
likely it will be likely to happen we
will see during the parliamentary
election okay
because we need to we need to get into
the parliamentary elections we've only
got a couple of minutes left i'm sorry
to interrupt you jack uh so ariane a
president with no majority has no power
we've got the parliamentary elections uh
coming up in the summer traditionally
you know the the winning presidency gets
the majority in parliament
do you think it's going to be a
different ball game this time rom
yes um
certainly if marinopan wins we know
that ever since they changed the the
timing of the parliamentary election and
put them after the presidential election
there's a momentum going in
however i don't see marinopan winning
an absolute majority just on a role
we also know that power attracts and i'm
sure she will be able to attract uh
people you know coming from the
traditional right possibly even
people from the left who are more the
kind of sovereign
sovereign sovereignist sorry uh left but
it is going to be uh difficult to get a
majority and obviously
depending on the majority she will be
able to to implement a program or not we
might even end up in a period of
cohabitation you never know if she wins
and people suddenly feel right okay we
better rectify this we might end up with
you know lupine president and a socially
uh a left-wing uh prime minister so it's
very much up in the air and i think you
are right to really point to the fact
that the the parliamentary election is
the key election because without a
majority presidents do not have power
if macron wins i think it's more likely
for him to have a majority maybe not an
absolute majority but enough to to
create you know a kind of coalition of
the willing so to speak okay we'll
closely follow this of course here on al
jazeera over the next two weeks very
closely indeed it's all we've got time
for uh jacqueline arianborgen and
elizabeth moutai we do appreciate your
time and your perspective on this thanks
a lot thank you too for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion just go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story
you can also join the conversation on
twitter our handle is at aj inside story
from me nick clark and the entire team
here in doha it's goodbye for now